Watch to the end of this video for an epic surprise
This is the last tick tock video
I'm ever doing one more and then we're done where it's a sale and we're cleaning out house
Likes freaking do this first up
Everyone's been sending me this I did this for pew die pie if you're not him keep scrolling, that's me
That at least I can respect if she does that for a video redemption complete
Redemption you are free. He will now pass the afterlife. You're welcome
Now no more no more
Channel clip in the bra. I can't see when a feat of Bob and 1450 is related song
Why are you rolling my phone like you'd want me like you wasn't pushing to kick to the sit down?
Are you even trying anymore as tik-tok just become me you're becoming soft? Okay you're becoming lazy
Gave me some original Thanks, please. What are you beauty pie?
Bumper gift
Burger ping boat Betty's the Basking who bought Bombur burger bean burger of his bum ones blood fungus
But best bit burns bout that by debuff goo bad. All right, I'm glad it's over. I'm glad this is the last
Man ever is he making fun of illiterate people
And that same illiterate yes
If it's making fun of mute this is so disrespectful oh
My god
Oh
You're wondering why I'm laughing because I can relate unlike you little man. Let's little Smurfs. I'm actually pull okay
Look how pulling I look down on you. That's a pretty
boy, prove it
Say something
Oh
My god, that was absolutely incredible people on the tick-tock are so talented. I wish I was talented like bang
Doing
My eyebrow brings all the boys to my page and they're like what's on your Oh No
Nope I'm not looking at this thank God. It's a life stick knock em over. I'm over it. I don't need this anymore. I'm going
You know, let's check what's on the front page here we go. Okay. What if again
The only addition 10% now add the cold pretty pipe
My queen yesterday I can't be bothered anymore
Girls expectation took that but it sure
Alright, we're next
Personality. Yeah, of course, of course
Pay for dinner
Alright, I guess one day it's fine
Say ball, what's under here? Oh
Hey for him accounts - well, yeah, we'll just do that
relationship
Keep up with a daily drama. That's fine. Let's just turn this on
Me
It's sinking I never done
It so unfair you don't have any of those you don't never like this guy
We're just friends
I
Don't know anything about these people what context let's be watch you. Absolutely moron
I hope you get bitten by raccoon get rabies and die a painful death
How could you not know that a crafting table requires a diamond? How long have you been claimed this his game?
There's a recent girlfriend left you furniture
Thanks for the $5
Rumors gotta be like the bachelors job ever if there's a grinding at the deal with all these board
Well, you're still at the same time playing game. It's nice
If someone gave you gave you like a devil gave you this choice right? You can play games for a living but also
You're a straight away. Oh god. I'm listening right now
Follow me alive. Come on guys
Oh my god
Is so weird when youtubers and whatever have what is that : Lee
Yeah, I do not look like Lele cons
You want me be Lele pons? I could be lily pond when you um, when your fucking homework is due. I
Me on New Deal oh
Yeah
You gotta get their Spanish you what part is latina. Did you know about this? Whatever don't you do?
All I want to know is what is Lily pons going to be in?
2019 rewind that's all I care about
Nothing else Rather's has this ever happened to you. I'm gonna teach you how to take them off
step on
step two just
Riot
Has this ever happened to you, isn't it? So annoying when you try and steal something?
Okay again, sometimes they forget to pull it up like I get that rubbing on last tick-tock guys
Let's get excited for the life. I'm surprised at the end if
remember
God it makes me so anxious to break the TV. I never know what people are gonna do these days
Fix your cable you call that cable management's what the frickin baking?
disgusting
Where's my smashing team?
If you're a woman you might want to keep scrolling unless you want to get a lady boner in three two
Oh-oh-oh-oh always useless talents somehow people get value out of it thanks to me. It's beautiful
Yeah
Back yeah, check out this cool lamp thing. I wonder what would happen if I rubbed it
you have summoned me a
Magical genie now. Tell me the first of your wishes three. Oh sweet
I wish that all genies had small dicks
Why
Now why would you do I wish that all genius had overly its large nipples
last
Tick-tock video. Thank God
Declaration of independence, so no. Hey
That is the saddest thing I've ever seen
Declaration of independence, how could you do this? Shake my hand never been so disappointed
Then should be powerful you finally woke up. Why are you invite me to your Bar Mitzvah bang?
Why man why
I'm gonna check with Ben Shapiro and make this right. How could you do this bin? I could do not invite at your Bar Mitzvah
It's Ben Shapiro is a baby that has an invite power to make or am I wrong?
Wait you invited your brother
Mastic
Okay, that was it that's all for tech talk forever, thank you guys we made it this far a hundred episode
Absolutely
Incredible if you enjoyed check out March and I see you guys tomorrow. Whoa
What?
super simulators becoming relevant
No, no, don't leave
No, please
Sponsor eagle please do something
Yes
This game is still relevant God dear me
You
There's no surprise